[MUSIC PLAYING]
GANESH JANAKIRAMAN:
Broadcom Software
is one of the world's leading
enterprise software companies,
modernizing, optimizing, and
securing some of the world's
largest, most complex
hybrid environments,
and have built a wide portfolio
of industry-leading enterprise
infrastructure and
security software,
have the privilege of leading
some of the best engineers
and architects as part of
the SaaS platform engineering
within Broadcom Software.
We believe that DevOps
is a culture that
fosters innovation, breaks
barriers between development
and operations teams, improves
efficiencies and productivity.
The primary business
drivers for this effort
was, again, the
diverse portfolio
of products that
we had within SaaS.
Broadcom grows organically
and inorganically
through acquisitions.
We acquired products that
are industry leaders, that
have grown over a
period of time, that
have built on different
technology stacks,
built with different
methodologies,
and run on on-prem,
private, and public clouds,
and operated differently.
We had to build a
common standard platform
where these products
could run, where
we could leverage
the efficiencies
across these products.
This common platform would
include Infrastructure
as a service and the
Kubernetes orchestration layer,
standard DevOps and security
practices adopted across,
and leveraging a common
set of DevSecOps tools,
like the CI/CD pipeline.
We understood that one
size doesn't fit all.
But it was surprising,
as we started
migrating many of
these products into
container-based architectures.
There are a lot
of common strands
across this wide,
heterogeneous set of workloads
that we had and the
security-- panoply of software
that we had.
We were able to extract a lot
of common strands across, say,
for example, observability, like
monitoring, metrics, alerting,
logging, and some
of the security
tooling that we could do that
could monitor this environment.
We were surprised to see the
amount of commonality which
was there that we
could leverage and make
this whole process
more efficient.
Google has been a strong,
reliable partner and a trusted
partner for us in this journey.
And it's fair to say that
without them, we would not
have been able to
accomplish what
we did over the last few years.
And this is a large program,
a lot of moving parts.
We did have challenges.
But Google was always
there, available to us,
responsive, and innovative
in their solutions.
Really, this transformation was
not possible without Google.
And we are definitely
thankful to Google for that.